Okay. So...um..I didn't-- I definitely didn't die in the first round.
And...it totally didn't happen.(rly mark)
This time for realsies. I'm not a scrub, I swear! (yes you are)
So. Now. Okay. [unintelligible] I didn't cheat.
Okay
Alright
Alright.
So you guys are gonna think I cheated,
I did not.
I played, and you would not believe the things--
Look at my popularity ranking. You would not believe it;
I came across something that offered me 50 popularity for a 25% chance--
I'll go back! It was true, I pushed it, I won it,  and-- (goddamnit mark we believe you)
I am not in the right-- where the f--
No
Hang on--
Wait
No you! Gah shit.
Aaaaah
[Muttering] Get awa- AW FUCK YOU! What the fuck happened?!
Okay- heh heh. There we go, okay.
Hang on. Everybody your freaking horses because--
Okay. Alright. So it's true. I'm in the wrong room. But don't blame me...
Random item...
[Muttering] Plus...critical...
Yay?
Yaaayyyy!
Okay.
Ok...Mystery box?
Snowf-GODDAMMIT
Okay.
So you guys are not gonna believe me but I--I'll port there right now--
I went there-- It's true! 100 percent true! (Hold. Your. Horses. Mark.)
I guarantee you. I'm not bullshitting
It's-- It was right here.
Yes!
This.
Okay, see!
It was...
Okay!
Alright.
I could-- Apparently, I could push this again.
*mark thinking to fuck up or not*
I don't wanna risk it, I'm already at 100.
But I pushed it
Ah!
[High pitched] Oh!
[Relieved sobbing sounds]
I did it again!
I did it for you to show you that it happened.
Okay.
So that's fine.
I did it.
So now I'm gonna get...
Past this boss
And I'm gonna get over to the area...
That you guys
Oh fuck wrong way
I-- I'm gonna get past this boss
I'm very popular right now
Immna- Immna get back to the third level
So that I can make some god damn progress!
Ow. What the?
Oh gOd daMn iT
daMn iT. Woahwoah
fuCK you. Oh god damn it this is going very poorly
I don't know why
Shouldn't be. This guy's easy
WoAh kaY
Alright I got him, okay
Get that
Get that..
What's in here, please something good, god damn it. Lock picks okay..
Alright.
Alright, okay, we're okay
I'm super popular
I am a god damn hero
I get 50 more *Mark making weird sounds while burping*
And accuracy, okay. What did you guys get me?
*if they gave me something bad*
What is that...
Oh Godddd noooooo... It's all a hallucination, I'm not actually popular!
oH eVERythINg's a liE
Photo of the kid who bullied you at school
Alright
Okay
Oh my god you guys are gonna pick lunacy for the next one.. oh geez
Oh this is too funny
Oh Jesus
I'm so boned..I'm sO bOneD
Oh god I love it
Okay.. immna get..
more defense, I'm gonna get more damage...
I'm gonna get.. more armor, 'cause apparently that's hard to come by.
Alright, come on, bring it on. Whaddaya got for me?
Nothin'.
So what do you got?
Whole lot of nothin'.
What is THAT?
What are THOSE? (Mark, please.)
Okay, got that taken care of, holy shit.
Woah-- OH GOD. The mushrooms are kicking in real bad, oh God, I can't--
Hoooh-- Bu-- fuck you!
Yes!!!
Yaaas... *KAWAII*
Okay. This's good, this's good, this's good...
[unintelligible]
Ohh, can't kill me.
Alright, what is this?
Random weapon?
Alright, sure.
Hey!
This looks cool! Why does it only have fiiiive bullets....?
I think RNG may have fubbernucked (fucked) me on this one.
Kay but I'll give 'em a try-- ohhhh
[unintelligible muttering] Fuckin' mushrooms, dude..... (drugs kickin in)
Ohhh, that's pretty cool.
Okay so it's not actually just-- okay--
Oh, sheez j-- [unintelligible]
Okay, this is actually pretty good.
Oh jeez. Ohh jeez.
Oh--
Wh-- okay, so they just go in a spray--
$7000 budget cuts? I dunno what that means.
Okay.
Ooh jeez, mystery box. Hello.
God damnit.
[imitating] Fwock.
Oh, that's not good. Okay.
Gotta moove, gotta move, gotta move.
Kay, haboosky.
Oh jeez-- What the fu--
What am I stuck on-- ah, Jesus.
God damnit, I need to stop reloading like that, I don't need to reload, why do I keep reloading?
Oh, cool.
I just got these, so that means I got more ammo, that's good.
Hokay-- [unintelligible] Hey baby, how's it goin'?
Don't mind, I'm havin' a real bad trip here.
Like, real-- woah, hey.
Okay, you got it, okay.
Woah, jeez-- ow, shit-- Man, this weapon is really good-- ow.
Ow-- Fuck-- No, you do not.
Don't do that shit to me.
Fuck the mushrooms!
Ooooh boy...
God damnit, fuck those icicles.
You are not gonna kill me, dude.
NO-- AAAAAH!
Ah, yeah, fuck you!
Fuck you, fuck you, fuck you.
Okay.
Oh, jeezums, yes!
Health, please.
Yes, tiny bits of health!
Oh yes, health! Thank you!
Oh God, I don't wanna say I'm a dick!
I am a bit of a dick, but I don't wanna say it out loud.....
Augh, maybe-- maybe I'll get help. Maybe I'll get help from you guys!
I'm a hero, after all!
Oh boy.
Ohh boy!
Ohhh boy!
GOD DAMNIT, I KNEW IT.
'You're not the first and definitely won't be the last contestant who went crazy during Killing Room.'
'But don't worry! Soon you will rest in peace.'
'You're hearing and seeing things.'
Thank you!
Oh, THANK YOU!
Oh, THANK YOU VERY MUCH, you guys are so nice.
Oh, you're so nice.
Oh boy.
I need more max health.
Need to do more damage.
I need more armor.
I need a lot of things.
The hammer ain't doin' so good.
Oh. Why is there a pony here?
Why is THAT there?
Okay...
I'm on SHROOMS and I'm seein' things...
Oh, wh-- Augh, I didn't reload, 'cause why would I do that? I'm such a dummy.
Aw, fuck. Aww, fuck.
Mmkay, we're gonna try some-- oh God, I can't--
Well, that's not good.
G-- Gangster style! Okay.
Well, that just hit me.
Hokay, wasting all my ammo...
Woah! Hey-- Oh, hey!
OH, hey!
Hi. Okay. That's weird.
Okay, goodbye! Thank you for visiting!
Oh-- OHH, COME ON!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no...
Don't sh-- I didn't shoot the robot!
Why are these guys so impossible, good God?
Okay.
Gotta buy this, gotta buy this, gotta buy a random item.
Gonna be good!
'You're lucky, sometimes you kill enemies with the first hit.'
Cool!
Wow, indeed.
Hokay, I am dying and this is bad,
I only have my pistol, and I'm seeing clowns.
This is going very poorly for me.
I don't even have weaponry!
Oh-- Invisible stairs?!
Does that mean?
Oh.
I-- I don't know what that means. Invisible--
Ohhhhhh...!
Ah, okay.
So I've gotta find the stairs?
Is that what I gotta do, or do I gotta make stairs?
Ohh God, this isn't-- oh, this isn't good for me.
Ohh God.
Ohh God. There's no way-- I'm not gonna make this.
Ohh, people are gonna hate me!
And then I'm gonna see more clowns! And then ponies are gonna fly by my face!
I am SO boneroned (boned).
Not gonna work.
Not gonna work, is it. Oh jeez, not gonna work.
Oop-- Nope, not gonna work.
Oh, fuck, dude, I wasn't ready for this.
Nope! That i-- That's not-- That's the opposite of okay. Well.
[unintelligble]
Hi, welcome. You wanna join me on this next one?
Augh, why?
God damnit.
Get outta here!
Get outta here!!
Oh, no, not 'use settings'!
'Use settings'?
You talking about my settings?
Settings? Options?
3-0-0-1, okay! Alright! 3-0-0-1.
Whooooooo!
What is that?
[gasp] I got a wasp!
Yay!
[imitating] Sa-nee indeed...
Okay, what do we got here? We got a whole assortment of stuff!
Ooh, that looks good.
Okay.
Let's see... Ryan's baby or this-- what's probably a plasma or frost launcher...
I'm gonna take Ryan's baby!
Okay then, the others exploded...
Also, I'm gonna try to open up this thing even though people don't want me to disturb the dead.
I can't fuck this one up!
[mumbling]
Ooh jeez...
Hi, thanks for the luck!
Okay.
Boo, I know, I need it!
So I got a weapon, I got some health.
I'm almost to the boss area.
I'm doing okay.
I'm not doing great but I'm doing okay.
I just wanna be able to use Ryan's baby and blast some enemies away.
Boo?
That doesn't do much.
Okay, got that one.
Easy enough.
Okay, I've got about as much health as I'm gonna get, so I guess it's time to go for this.
As much as people don't really like me right now, I've gotta fight a boss!
We're finally doing new bosses-- the only thing I really wanted here, so... we're doing good.
Hi! Eugh, oh God, why does it gotta be a worm?
It's gonna be a big'un, isn't it?
Oh God, clown!
Uh oh. That's a lot of people who didn't make it through this one.
Uh--hiii, okay.
Heh, good one. That probably is gonna work.
Insulting-- augh.
God! Of course!
Hah.
Oh-- great time for the shrooms to kick in.
Okay, until I know exactly what I'm up against, I'm gonna use my pistol.
Oh, that's-- That's not good.
Wh- Guhhh, why now?!
Ahh-- hit the butthole!
Oh jeezums.
Okay, that's-- that's not good.
Oh jeez. I gotta move.
Oh, it's got-- it's got things on the sides.
Ohhh, okay.
I got ya.
Ohhh okay, I'm seein' it, okay. Now that I know kinda generally what to--
Oh, you're just gonna poop out more worms.
This is awfully nice.
But please don't.
Kay-- oh, jeez, what was that?
Hooh, you're fast-- fuck, who's doing that?
Hoh-- Oh, it's you, oh God.
God damnit, oh, that's not good.
Ahhhh, not the best time!
Not the best time!
Ahh, I gotta hit it in the holes.
Ow, fucking--fuck you!
Holy shit!
Come on! Oh, I'm so close!
Why now? Oh Jesus.
That would've been the end of me. Come on, come on!
Finish him the fuck off!
Oh, finish him off!
Yes! Finally, god damnit, yes!
[screams] Oh, Jesus. I thought that was gonna kill me.
Oh my God, I'm on shrooms and everything is horrible!
Quick hands?
Ohh, thank you. Auto mag reloading...
That's so nice. And what is this?
Ohh, yes! Oh, yes! Ohh, yes!
Alright, okay, this is good.
This is good. I don't even need to say I'm a dick, I got a better pistol, which has been the only thing I've been using this whole time.
And!
I'm still a hero!
I get doublejump, hell yeah...
And then ammo capacity has increased!
Hell yeah!
Oh my God, what'd you guys give me?
[gasps, shouts excitedly]
Oh thank you!
I get doublejump AND that?
Oh, that's so nice.
Oh, that's so nice!
Oh, you guys are so nice...
Oh, you guys are so nice. I'm gonna reroll this to something more interesting.
Ooh! Aw jeez.
That's not good but it's-- it's a nice statue-- Okay, we'll do that one.
Oh, boy.
That's what I need-- I was so slow, that was my problem.
Wasn't able to ever do anything.
So I have very few bad items, besides the lunacy ones, but I got a lot of good items.
So I'm going to save and exit here, because, holy shit, I wanna keep going on that one,
So... Thank you for helping me, thank you for hindering me.
So thank you, everybody who helped out.
And thank you, everybody, so much for watching.
Let me know what you thought of this down in the comments below.
I had a lot of fun with it, it was really cool to have you guys helping me out in whatever way there was to help out.
Hopefully I can do this in a livestream at a future point so you can see and affect it right on screen.
But thanks again, everybody, so much for watching, and, as always, I will see you in the next video!
Bye-bye!